We're asked to graph the
proportional relationship shown
in the table below.
And they give us a
table of x values,
and the corresponding y values.
So we see when x is equal
to 0, y is equal to 0.
Then they give us a
bunch of other points.
When x is 3, y is 0.5.
When x is 6, y is 1,
so on and so forth.
So let's graph one of
these that actually
have integer values
for both coordinates.
So when x is 6, y is 1.
So we only need two points
to specify the line.
So we've actually graphed it.
But then they also ask us,
what is the slope of this line?
And we just have to
remind ourselves.
Our slope is what is our change
in y for a given change in x.
So, for example, or another
way to think about it,
what is your change in
y over your change in x?
So here, our x changed by 6.
It went from 0 to 6.
And our y changed by 1.
So our change in
y over our change
in x, which is the definition
of slope, our change in y
is 1, when our change in x is 6.
See that right over here.
Change in y, 1 when
our change in x is 6.
Let's check our answer.
We got it right.